the heart-wrenching goodbyes
loved ones not knowing when they will
unite again
women and children heading west to
relative safety
often leaving men behind
males between the age of 18 to 60 are
not allowed to leave the country in
these times of war
among them foreigners also trying to get
out
joseph is a medical student from ghana
he arrived in dinipro less than a year
ago hoping to one day become a heart
surgeon
now he just hopes to reach any border
there's a third time i've been at the
train station i missed the first and the
second one
well the struggle was tough because i'm
trying to um
rush into words
and then um the first time i got into
the train i was literally suffocating so
i had to get down because it was super
overcrowded
so
that's how come we stayed so this time
train rides are for free but it's on a
first come first served basis
so no one is guaranteed to leave without
a long wait
here at the bus station there are only a
few rides available and that's only to
the surrounding villages otherwise there
are no buses anymore because the
destinations are either out of reach or
the road is too dangerous so people like
fumi and rose now need to find another
way to get out of the city
both are students from nigeria they
continued attending classes until the
first day of russia's assault on ukraine
reaching the decision to go was not easy
i witnessed the first war in 2014 in
lagos it was brutal it was bad
which was why i had to live to nigeria
because it affected my education so now
i just came here in april i struggled to
come back to finish my final year in
april
so now i'm like three months to writing
my final exam and this happened again
so it's kind of a difficult decision to
just say oh the world is coming let me
just go back to nigeria again
they are trying to reach the romanian
border with no bus in sight they head
back to the train station
only to find themselves rushing to the
shelter among hundreds of ukrainians on
the move
this family fled the donets region ahead
of another possible takeover by the
russian-backed separatists they are
trying to calm down genie
and worried of the long trek ahead
meanwhile rose and sumi are looking into
other options to evacuate so not today
huh no not today tomorrow or next maybe
but for now
they like many others will have to
return home hoping tomorrow is a better
day
hamid al jazeera disney pro in eastern
ukraine